ارجع عن الخطا واستداره كامله الصين وبعد
اجراءات متشدده ولقاحته السنوفارم ومعركه
سياسه صفر كوفيد تلجا اخيرا الى باب
لطالما رفضت طلقه سابقا
بكينيا
في البلاد تتجه غربا تجري محادثات مع شركه
فايزر الامريكيه وفق مصادر حصريه لوكاله
رويترز البحث عن العقار وليس اللقاح
رويترز نقلنا عن مصادرها تقول ان الصين
تجري محادثات مع شركه فايزر للحصول على
ترخيصا يسمح لشركاتها بتصني وتوزيع عقار
باك سلوفيت المضاد لكوبيد والفيروسات في
الصين
مباحثات صينيه حديثه مع فايزر تتراسها
الاداره الوطنيه للمنتجات الطبيه تعكس
حرصا صينيا على الانتهاء من اتفاق الترخيص
قبل الثاني والعشرين من يناير الحالي
في الامس كانت بكين تعارض الى حد كبير
اللقاحات والعلاجات الغربيه لا بل وتشكك
بها غير ان موجات الاصابات الكبيره تضع
بكين امام الخير وربما الممر
سيناري اوروبا ما لم تكن تتخيله السلطات
بعد قرارها بالتخلي عن سياسه صفر كورونا
الشهر الماضي والان تواجه المستشفيات
الضغوط شديده وقله في الادويه وضعوني يثير
جدلا قديما حول سنفارم يتجدد اليوم في
موطن اللقاح في التشكيل كلها
نسبه فعاليه اقل بكثير من لقاحات فايزر
ومديرنا وقتها كما فشلت اللقاحات الصينيه
ايضا في صدها متحولات كورونا لا سيما
سلاله دلتا المتحور انذاك
اما اليوم تتفاقم المخاوف من محدوديه
بيانات التسلسل الجني الوبائي والفيروسي
المتاحه بشان الاصابات في الصين وهو ما
يثير القلق من عوده العالم الى مربع لا
يريده ابدا